PAVLOS PROTOPAPAS: Every single
minute, computers across the world
collect millions of gigabytes of data.
What can you do to make sense
of this mountain of data?
How do data scientists process
this wealth of information
and use it in the applications
that power our modern world?
Data is the fuel for the digital age.
It powers machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
Data scientists use this fuel to conduct
research, find results, and communicate
their findings.
You will leverage the power of
Python and apply to real life data
science problems.
You will explore applications
in various domains,
hone your intuition for the
theory underlying these methods,
and consider different ways of verifying
your models to identify and reduce
potential biases.
Job prospects for data
scientists are growing.
And the knowledge and skills
gained from these courses
will open up your world to machine
learning and artificial intelligence.
Learn data science.
And process the fuel that
powers our modern world.